it's time for seen and unseen when we
reveal the stories behind the headlines
for that we turn to Fox News contributor
and author of the new book The
Magnificent Mischief of Tad link and
Raymond Royo all right Ray on Monday we
um half in just suggested that Biden had
declared a new foreign policy Doctrine
yeah the don't don't don't Doctrine
which he rambled out during a 60 Minutes
interview for those who missed it
earlier Laura he made the doctrine
formal today my message to any state or
any other hostile actor thinking about
attacking Israel Remains the Same as it
was a week ago don't don't don't didn't
need it he couldn't have shrunken it
down to one don't this could be the
bumper sticker for his next campaign La
Biden 2024 don't don't
don't all right Raymond I want to get
your reaction to something else Biden
said
today the vast majority of Palestinians
are not
Hamas Hamas does not represent the
Palestinian
people La what is he talking about they
won 76 seats of
132 in back in 2006 that was the last
time they had an election clearly the
majority of Palestinians wanted this
terrorist organization now they got them
and Hamas has been very successful they
scuttled the Saudi Arabia peace deal
with Israel and they today because they
blew up their own Hospital stopped both
Jordan and Egypt from meeting with the
president so far they're running the
narrative here that's got to
end well well he he was so convincing
though overseas President Biden I mean
he had jet lag when he when he does when
he does the speech tomorrow night
imagine the jet lag but at least they'll
have the teleprompter it'll be better
for him um well let's El while the
president is spending billions on the
war in Ukraine and Israel Mickey Mouse
is fattening the coffers of that unseen
force behind so much of this China
Disney is announcing a deal with the
Chinese controlled Tik Tock to create a
new Disney destination for fans to
engage Disney music videos Games Etc
luring children to hand over their
personal information via the app to the
Chinese Communist while making Disney a
bundle this is
horrendous now it was back in 2019 I
believe Raymond four years ago that Mike
um Pompeo came on the show and said if
you're watching this and you're a parent
delete it from your phone immediately
and probably throw away your phone you
probably can't even have your phone uh
get a new phone after deleting uh
putting downloading that so it's
horrible all right I'm glad to see at
least one politician Raymond is taking a
stand on this though Governor Sarah
Huckaby in Arkansas is throwing the
Chinese out of her State watch I'm
announcing that senta a Chinese
state-owned agrochemical company must
give up its land Holdings in Arkansas s
Genta owns 160 acres in Northeast
Arkansas which it uses primarily for
seed research seeds are technology
Chinese state-owned corporations filter
that technology back to their Homeland
stealing American Research and telling
our enemies how to Target American
Farms other Governors better catch good
for Huckabee Sanders yeah I'm so glad
she made that stand yeah there's that
Arkansas law that forbids China from
owning land in the in their state this
should be a national law we should not
have the China gobbling up all of these
lands across the country and these
corporations like Disney better get wise
too uh but you know the Chinese
influence law I is yet another reason
why the Republicans should be wearing
sackcloth and Ashes this week for
failing to elect a speaker today Jim
Jordan lost two votes to become speaker
22 Republicans voted against him and now
there's talk that Congressman Dave Joyce
of Pennsylvania is going to introduce
legislation to expand the powers of the
speaker protim and make Patrick McKenry
the temporary speaker with full Powers
this is a ruinous idea I
think well he's he's the favorite
candidate I think right now Wall Street
and he's of the pro-china caucus because
he's really doesn't want to put any you
know blockade or any regulations on
businesses investing in China so he's
been a real you know advocate for more
American businesses to go over to China
that's a real problem especially when
China's working against us in Ukraine
pretty much in the Israeli conflict so I
I don't get this at all but lur he
hasn't been elected he was appointed by
Kevin McCarthy you need somebody who's
elected by the Full House and you can't
change these rules this is the guy who's
third in line for the president the
house Speaker controls all the bus
theule the bills the money for the
country this is far too important a
position to not have the full house vote
on a candidate put one forward and the
GOP is denying the American people a
branch of government this has got to end
right now I I I got to tell you I've
been we're looking at these protests
across the country right now um in New
York City uh they're growing uh protest
across New York City tonight and also in
Chicago where the protests are growing
louder and bigger uh and to to look at
these scenes Raymond it seems
like this is this is something like
you'd expect in maybe the Middle East or
I don't know you don't you don't expect
it in the United States of America but
there you have it St PA people acting
they're they're responding to Hamas they
called for protests around the world
you're seeing them this is very
revealing and
troubling the propaganda works
I mean in in St Paul Minnesota who would
have think it but I think we have about
80,000 Somali living in St Paul now more
than that now and that that this that's
what they think about that hospital
bombing uh Raymond great to see you as
always thank you so much thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else